like it's wild that i'm sitting across
from you and that i get to do this thing
and it's not anything that ever found
its way into my version of the franklin
planner it's this
tension between yes you want to set
goals for yourself and you want to work
hard and show up and be diligent but
also you have to make space for the
miracle because you can't imagine
what your life could possibly be right
like you have to you have to hold that
that that
tension with the goals that you're
seeking a little bit loosely so you can
make space for
stuff that you can't even predict for
yourself and for me
it always goes back to
the inside job like how much am i
working on myself where are my blind
spots where are the things that you know
i could be more grateful and it seems
completely disconnected from whatever
goal i'm seeking in the external world
but all i know is that when i'm when i'm
engaged in that process that's where i'm
sort of taking that insurance policy out
on greater possibility that i can't
quite fathom exactly